okay so today we are going to speak
again about the polls because this is
like the theme of our lecture a secret
life of pause I would like to speak
about one of the main feature of the
poem is going forward and trying to get
you know their ultimate goal like the
promotion so although when you know the
first steps of chess were made in the
ancient times pawns were mainly used
like in sacrifice is a kind of a
sacrifice and all the time
nowadays we respect much more the pawns
and it's act with Vidura who had like a
very famous phrases pawns are the saw of
the game the first game I want to
present and okay this is like the the
name of the the lesson today because
I've called it like pawns rolling in
because okay this is their main function
going forward and trying to get their
promotion so it reminds me a little bit
one song which a few years ago became
quite popular of Adele famous singer
rolling in the deep' so that's why our
pawns you know like to get rolling in
and in this game especially it was
played in a modest tournament it was a
kind of almost close to him and there
were a few local players with the less
strength and a couple of grandmasters so
during this tournament in one moment I
get to okay I did need but I just went
to play an active tournament in
Barcelona which I played very well in in
one but because of this draw I had to
catch up with the leader of the
tournament so I did the last the last
round of the tournament night I don't I
played with Grandmaster panchenko from
Russia and it was needed to become a
Nassau winner the tournament just just
to win so a draw was not ended so by a
pure coincidence but also by a lot of
effort during the whole the whole
tournament because it was played in nine
days I started one of his pad line
helped by a fellow Grand Master dashi
was passive which we are still friends
so he played like a quite risky line in
the electric defense his favourite
opening line and we studied side this
line for eight days so when the last one
was played in the morning probably he
told it okay I will not have enough time
to prepare but we can put a lot of hours
like at least more than than 10 hours so
okay the whole this game which you'll
see it's exactly in our team that the
pawns falling in was played in 10
minutes my time and basically I just
used the time just to move the pieces
because I have started so well this
mission so I remembered almost all of
the lines and okay in this time town for
the the engines were quite good but not
as good as nowadays so we have to invest
a lot of our ideas because it's a
special position you see you you
sacrifice in our poll you have a
obviously development and you have a lot
of ideas but we try to find out the most
on planet and maybe like the most exact
and I taught it by our modest efforts we
succeed in that and the sweet reward was
this a devastating loss for panchenko I
mean in the end of the game which was a
very short game he was in severe time
travel it didn't help at all because the
position was completely lost and just I
told you earlier I spent like 10 minutes
about the whole game so he plays a
legend and in this patient not the
normal ethics but he plays a very risky
line which is 96 of course here we have
prepared exactly the line and which I
have played here there is also c4 Knight
b6 e 6 this sharp line but I told that
in the main line which he has played a
few games there is like a pawn sacrifice
quite an obvious one which looks quite
suspicious for black so I played Castle
well on castle detection e5 Knight takes
25 I will not show you all the lion
allies because they have a lot of lines
or try just to keep the spirit of the
game just to give you exactly the
feeling which probably my opponent had
during these very disasters for his game
there is also a line starting with
Bishop e2 when he take the central pawn
but okay this position is also very well
analyzed by us during the tournament
it's a very difficult one very difficult
for black in my opinion so but there is
no need to look at the lines just let me
show you what happen in the game so
Knight X 25 this is what he used to play
now if it takes for me to I take with
the Queen threatening route d1 also
threatening immediately Queen B 5 which
gives me time and having my net okay he
is behind in development it's quite
risky so he used to play Bishop a5 like
he played in this game c4 Knight b6
Queen b3 well this has already been
played in one of his games and after e6
route d1 and now the Queen has problems
where to go for example the active Queen
h4 he's made by C if I know and you
started losing material so he played in
this game with a fellow Grandmaster and
a rather strong one and a friend of mine
kornei from Russia so in this game I
think he played like 28 then the Queen
goes to g3 he has problems how to
develop kicking side and ok he quickly
got into into big problems and lost this
game I'm not sure if you lose the game
but he had very early a very difficult
pushing out of the opening I mean we can
say that almost lost all running
position so K in this game I was sure
that he'll go for the the principle move
Queen d4 [ __ ] starts you know buying
time and also at start to doing some
time and also of course attacks a
central pawn for the central pawn ok
it's a very important if you can win a
central pawn so you can use some time
and neglect development but to certain
limit so this precise question which you
analyzed a lot ok it was even
recommended in some comments of maybe
this game with no it kornev although
here they recommend after this move rule
d1 d1 and but the position which we have
looked for sometime this one with c6
just to give you an idea well we thought
it Y can get something better
mean this didn't feel like like enough
so that's why we found ideas which are
basically human and checked all the
lines thoroughly through many years with
my computer trying to find like that the
best but many of the have the ideas
which it came up we're not the first one
suggested by the computer so Bishop f3
is a move we liked a lot although he has
like a wide choice here you can play
Ruby 8 you can even play that we analyze
even the just to show you one line the
absurd even so everything was analyzed
here even Bishop c8 he plays Bishop b4
then of course we win more time like you
see for our development so it's becoming
a little bit very hard to suspect that
he'll survive here when he has not still
developed you know the whole King site
and you are already entering with the
roots into play like here roots even
Knight d4 so you see the white army is
playing and black is still quite
underdeveloped so here he taught of
course a lot I was just coming on the
brought playing my move because really
this position was quite familiar for me
and he chose here I don't know what
he'll choose but ok I mean I didn't
matter too much because really this
patient was quite known to me on 365 I
liked on here on this move I like very
much 93 it's not like the only move you
can have a lot of options because
obviously you have a compensation but
here the idea is how to get like the
best benefits because the 1983 team go
to b5 but sometimes you can go to c4 so
it has a various interesting routes and
I liked a lot but ok no need to look at
Indy line just I want to give you the
feeling of the game so he casts out long
and now the Pawn Stars rolling in
because ok this quite measure the pawns
roll just against his King and having
invited both Bishop look in this
direction this should be very very
suspicious lesion of course it's good to
know it concretely also because doing
during a game if you have not analyzed
thoroughly yeah you can make some
mistakes but this was not the case of
this game so castle
four and now he taught a lot but okay
here all the alternatives were heavily
analyzed so he had Bishop d3 Luke g1
he had like Queenie six trying a little
bit to stop your but ninety-two simple
you know depending and still threatening
a five
he could have sacrificed an exchange but
because of the lack of development all
these sacrifices could not be successful
like here Rudy three queen bee five
still you know wanting to push the pawn
just one line let me show you
so rookie three four examples
sacrificing an exchange is followed by
mate like thank you but no I prefer like
if we place a six it was also not good
because of this simple tactic so here of
course the way he already says that
probably this game won't be oh and take
his list of his favorite games but it
was a little bit too late now
so Queen a5 of course I remembered this
line which was played in the game c5
which also played immediately and now of
course a very natural move because
although you have an attack you offer an
exchange of Queens but it's a first move
after the exchange you know he loses the
pawn a 7 in the tech continues although
although you know it's like it may feel
like an end game but it's really a
middle game because in all the the heavy
pieces the rooks are on the boat you
have minor features and he does not have
I mean he has like the bishop on a face
and a rock on it which are like that you
the end of the game which is very close
now so I don't know if you miss this
move but away now it's now it's too late
because now you're attacking two pieces
the Queen and in the night so he gets to
exchange yeah the game looks completely
terrible for black but I assure this was
like a real sweet victory because of a
lot of work of course it's not like that
always when you put some work into
different lines
it's got reward sometimes it may never
happen
so it's not like like they say that is
10 or phrase it always when you put a
lot of effort in in some line sooner or
later it will be played well I've kept
cases that it was never played
so it's not like in in fairy tales but
sometimes you get you know the happy
moment like this
now I defy fructose on a seven well here
it's already late but because like I
told you earlier
now that continues and it's it's quite
natural because you have too many pieces
you know participating and he has like
quite a lot of kiss pieces like half his
army looking know what will happen with
his skin so to keep late c6 but our King
b8 with b6 like I told you it continues
the attack c6 and then 93 until now I
remember the type may be the only time I
thought a little bit was in completely
winning position from 93 did this has
been has been known so this is like the
18 mode and basically I don't see any
sensible move here for him because
everything is is falling apart you're
threatening almost everything nor okay 1
b6 with some mating thread I mean he
played Knight takes me three exchange is
one of your bishop but what metals in
chest and what we see here is what is
left on the body notes left is the
bodies all of my army creating
threatened you know he kept like the
rook on d8 which is also in danger so
it's really very sad so he plays Bishop
d5 and now this like the only moment I
just have to choose which line because
everything wins very easily so I took
with the bishop but okay this also does
not leave you know too many questions
Bishop e2 and okay all kinds of mating
motives now because now you have their
oaken in the Bishop attacking his kiss
King visual basic Ruby are okay one I
mean different type of mates but I
preferred you know just to also to get
the pawns Maureen I preferred take with
the bishop here and now g6 because okay
now sometimes you you have you know this
Maltese when when the knight our prison
on b5 you immediately threatening okay
eight mate so here he resigned because
okay I mean he's
the most unpleasant picture of his
position is you know the kingside which
is still under development
and you're threatening everything like
Ruby 7 ok 1 or k 8 mate
so here the pawns really got and got
their reward in a fairly easy easy
fashion but I just want to show this
game which in itself looks like a
complete annihilation but it was not
like something which came out of nothing
so it was a lot of effort before this
game just to get to this result just
look even even the rukon f1 no way kick
changed v3 even the rookie is
threatening the poor nation although I
don't intend to take this pawn but just
in case you know just in case you also
have threats like even Knight e4 Knight
b6 for example also you know with this
kind of making threats know also
possible imagine for example if I play
Knight e4 you know take take she's
excited I'm turtling Knight b6 would be
7 one of the many checkmates know there
are a lot of them here so ok he finally
had enough and residing in this game so
when we talk about the pawns
I remember one thing quite distinctly
because you remember this kind of a
curious detail so the only game which I
played not sure if he was an
international mastic he became
intentional master he was much older
than me so he played in some kind of a
team championship and the only guy with
a level of master maybe he was the
International Master Polito from
Bulgaria an old player in which I have
like the most number of connected
passport so I have five connected passed
most it was from a French which I played
whenever with back which was not very
usual for me to play the French but I
use it in the last Olympiad I played I
played only Frank because I kept time
just to prepare especially for this will
impede so in this game with 3 if I had 5
passports and they were not on the
initial position so they are rolling in
and he and he okay I told he'll resign
because I get like a rook a bishop and
five passports and [ __ ] the Queen
maybe some are Pend Oreille it was like
water polo muy but the guy didn't resign
so yeah he made some kind of a bravery
okay
inside me I was I have to confess I was
a little bit laughing and enjoying the
whole so he he took some of my paws
because I got I was enjoying because I
he succeed to take a rock and three paw
but okay at the end it was left a bishop
and two passports which of course made
made quiz and he resigned but this is
like the the game which I clearly
remember with the major number of
connected passports and I'm not
referring to a friendly game like a
serious game so the next game I want to
show which also has to do with our team
let's flip the bottles with black knit
was placed in an open tournament in
Greece is Aldo Leopold's but my opener
was a young and quite talented Greek
play and I saw that he was playing
against neither of [ __ ] p2 so I told it
may be something like that will be
played but for my surprise she played a
line which I used to play quite a lot
with Bishop III so here I get to
remember during the game an analysis
which I have made some time ago which
included a very interesting sacrifice
which probably is not entirely correct
so they're very a lot of alliance but
the end game the end game which which
happen in because okay during all these
like a CF lines basically it was not
very easy for him to find like the best
continuation see so keep Joe's
simplification and of course we got into
an endgame in which like the power of
the pawns was clearly visible so he 593
this is depletion online which I like to
play with white of course I've played
with both colors the the sharp lines
with 93 you know Bishop e6 f3 through b7
and so I played from white site and from
the black side but Knight f3 was my
favorite to play like a position online
mainly not trying to control the d5
square it has a lot of details so Queen
c7 a foreign it was not very pleasant to
play against the line which I play but
it has one advantage that I can employ
some analysis which I remembered
although this one in this one was not
very easy to remember so
castle Bishop e2 97 and now he plays
they get the exact in the very correct
approach because the idea of black just
let me show is if your castle here like
automatic move you play 95 here Bishop
e6 and now if he plays Bishop g5 you get
90 d7 so you're not obliged to take with
the with the bishop on f6 and to give up
you know that control the d5 square and
you are very flexible now the bishop on
g5 does not make any sense but our gate
here the position and it's quite
comfortable public and it has been
played so I knew that and he taught it
in the opening but he found like the
most logical and the most the principle
aligned here with 92 here what I have in
mind and what I paint in this game there
was 95 this interesting idea now I'll
show you what is the let's say like the
the the real essence of this idea
because if you play like the normal
theory which I like to play from the
white side this one now you have
strategic problems and I knew that no
need to look at this position which
having played quite a lot but all right
here you can have like problems with the
with the square d5 in a lot of lines
like for example let's say let's play
Bishop e6 and now you can get pros with
a pawn it a six years if you play Bishop
d7 now he takes play Knight c4 and start
you know piling up pieces here on the d5
square and immediately if you take me
for tea place 19 d5 and you got into
some tactical problems so let's see my
idea because it includes
quite a few details and like I told you
at the beginning it's not objectively
quite good if white knows exactly what
to do and if you can sanitize this
patient which of course was not the case
in this game so 9594
exactly you know the the precise move
now he wants Knight b6 and okay if you
if you want to play something like
Bishop e6 if you don't go into the idea
with the exchange sacrifice then of
course he has like a clear please no
advantage no dissipation you don't like
to have in idle because you know
he controls the situation and you don't
have to count the place so basically
night off like in many other lines but
especially in night of which like a
sharp line although this is like one of
the most positional lines
you always you know strive to give a
counter play
so here night x1 e4 and we enter into
this idea Knight b6 group b8 oh this is
like a first line 95 Queen d7 and now
Bishop a7 well if you plays Bishop f3
here I have such an idea here and now e4
sacrifice an exchange in such a way
let's let's look like for example like
not the best let's say if you place here
I take here and I'm getting you know
temp or temple this was analyzed so it
was not like over the board some
initiative now with this move although
he can take campus on the the basic idea
you can see it I'm moving time I'm
trying Bishop b7 and he cannot you know
safe immunity the bishop so he's having
some tactical problems like here here
and now even the King can have like
problems so Bishop a7 he thought here
but ok he found like the most natural
rocky 8 and all night b6 well if he if
he tries to repeat moves I could be soup
here why I would not have played of
course Ruby 8 now I kept Bishop d8 here
covering the basic square 96 obviously
has like a compensation but I have a
central pawn and if you compare to the
previous game well a central Pony is
good now at least I'm not getting made
it and not so he cares like a clear
position on compensation but you know
like ninja which used to writing in his
book so central pawn assured you know
very important game so you can suffer
quite a bit for a central pawn if it's
not something like destructive like a
disease if attack against your king so I
was ready to play this position but here
Knight b6 and now the whole idea I don't
know until what moment he saw that
but for me it was familiar so now you
play Knight x1 f2
like I told you it was studied
beforehand so this was like an idea
which I have analyzed well the idea is
to buy time you know if he takes you
give check and then you take you know
the bishop on a7 if you take some d7
what he played which is slightly you
know getting some kind of a panic then
of course you've got a good positional
compensation he of course the whole line
is quite suspicious between because of
Queen d5 there are a lot of lines you
know I have alternatives like create the
rookies hang in there you know on h1 so
just to show you a few lines like here
here
Knight b6 but basically it's it's quite
suspicious for for black but way he
hunter under the pressure of playing a
lion which was I was playing quite fast
in for him it was like maybe this move
for surprise he I don't know or when he
was entering the line he decides you
know to pay out let's say let's play
like an endgame because I have an
exchange but for the exchange you have a
clear compensation in the form of two
pawns so basically you probably like
have like a small material advantage and
also very important feature about the
position is much easier to play with
black after that the important thing was
just to to make some practical decisions
I'll show you now these decisions which
in my opinion were important in the
endgame this is like you know a very
good decision for black because now the
position becomes technical and basically
in my opinion there are only two results
on the broad now you see so you take on
the run he takes here now you have a
choice here I have looked in this
patient until now so here I have to play
by myself because obviously black has a
conversation but how you do it
well I prefer to take on a seven because
this Knight takes on be to Bishop III d5
let's say Ruby run here here this is not
so clear because he has activity and you
try to limit you know his routes which
need to open first to last activity so
this is like more unbalanced position
you compare this to what happen in the
game and I prefer to you know to have
the other way because it has like a more
solid bone structure and I almost don't
see any counter play for him and you see
the difference between how the the
computers think about a certain kind of
endgame so here I played Luke a7 he take
I take here with the King because okay
here like I said in my comment obviously
in my opinion black is the only one with
which I'm winning chances let's look
again at the material so I have seven
points gets five points
he's an exchange up so basically I feel
like a small material advantage in my
opinion of course these are just you
know accounting the material there are
other factors like if he has like a
clear play this is like very important
because I don't see clear playful right
so he has to be on the defensive so
Bishop c4 and I made a rather natural
for human decision I try to get the play
into a very clear territory to know
exactly what I am doing
so here the suggestion of the computer
after the game now which I look like to
play g6 into play f5 really does not
seem does not seem so natural to me
because much more important for us
humans not only for me I guess is to get
like much quicker some coordination
between the pieces normally a human does
not like you know just to put the pawns
in the rooks takes two on a seven so I
want to get my piece into play the
computer is very happy here but I'm not
happy and when you play a game you'd
like you know to feel good and to know
exactly what's happening on the ball so
here I thought it is better you know to
exchange two of the poles but to get you
know all of my pieces back into play
because then it becomes the type of
patient which I told you earlier with
only two results and obviously I'm
pressing the king will be in the center
so he castles f6 rook takes from d6 now
he could have played before but I still
you know I play here and I play b6 and
my piggies start getting into play the
bishop takes on b6 that C file can be
used so he has to be you know the pawn
starts rolling in you know slowly but
okay
you always have to to mine it okay he
exchanged a pawn
here at c3 King h7 Rudy - now it's time
to get your PC into play and now the
basic problem which you have is of
course the pawns which like is the name
of resin will start sooner or later and
you prefer sooner but the way you have
to prepare them to start rolling in but
also he doesn't get black squares this
is also always the kind of static
problem you have when you open a case
like a pair of Bishops one type of
square has much more chances to become
weak in your camp because the natural
defender these squares is is not on the
broad of course it depends on the
patient if it's like a static position
it's a closed one model but you have to
have always in mind that so b5 here
check here h6 well this is like a rather
you know cautious decision probably
better immediately h5 no need you know
just to grab more and more space and
just start running the poll but okay
because this is the type of questions
when you don't need to hurry
you know just need to to make it to
improve your position step by step like
you see no obvious counter play the
rooks does not have anything to attack
so I play to h6 here Bishop e6 well it
was more natural trying you know to try
to exchange one of the bishop with
Bishop f5 but still it's from a
practical point of view this patient is
very difficult to play with with white
so I cannot blame my open on that keep
playing somehow badly here it's really
very difficult to attain this kind of
endings because like I told you one
result is practically not on the boat I
mean Black has to do something like a
big blunder to give some chances here
I mean to lose the game rook e1 a 5
well you even try to grab more more more
space and of course you can fix another
weakness like on beto which is always
good bishop Seto group c7
of course you don't you don't have to
play a 4 because the pawn on e5 is
dependent so you combine them out if you
keep him guessing what will happen
sometimes before sometimes say 4
depending but the rook on c7 has a a
very good
vision because it stopped pressing you
know the the the queenside
now a key place h3 they like it all now
I liked before like before because the
rock on c7 attacks the pollen see true
and when they exchange this pond then
the bishop gets the incredible Square D
for and when the bishop is on d4 and all
of your bishops are centralized then the
pawns you know starts rolling because
they're this is what they expect but
first you have to create the conditions
you know because if if they're not
prepared the rooks you know can start to
attack them but when you have domination
because okay if you compare a bishop on
d4 with the rook on dito I can tell that
the rookies better know so before take
take Bishop e4 now b-tree well this is
like easy to understand move you could
have play something else but still no
need to care it so you fix a target on
b2 and this is a real target because you
have a dark squared Bishop now you fix
the target and then you see what will
happen
the b3 pawn cannot be attacked look the
one Bishop d4
Bishop d5 so you seen it okay my
opponent was defending quite creatively
now here is some tactic because if I
take you take rotation D for this is the
idea you know anyway with good chances
to survive I could have taken bishop
takes on b2 when I have given but okay I
mean now you lose the the b-pawn and the
material gets less so of course for
against - you can try but because it's
on one flank he's getting more chances
you know to to to make a draw which is
not what you really want and especially
you want to make his defensive tack much
more unpleasant so here probably he has
missed one intermediate move Bishop f2
which changes a little bit depletion
because if you place let's say okay one
then you play up c2 and the big
difference you can you can see the point
B trees to your life and the e pawn with
the bishop on f2 which we all have to
get such kind of Bishop you know if this
bishop then gets to g3 I began to get
even mating mating motifs know so this
is very comparing
played hooky - you also have a temper
move we should always look you know in
all kind of situational chess of
distemper move so this kind of rookie -
a very you know because this is a
deflection if he takes it can sustain
all the porn or the bishops of course
tube - bishops with the four pawns
against - we win against Rubin is his
b-pawn is going nowhere because the
bishop was so powerful that you know
they just tear you apart now he could
get played like that but no this kind of
tactics I easy to spot because okay you
just have one extra piece let's say on
the back squares there there is nobody
guarding so okay this for example also
is transformational vision into a
completely lost and game with two extra
pawn something like that happen in the
game so Bishop e6 but all right here
because probably he means bishop at all
the patient becomes fairly technical one
and okay this is like we see another
example this is very standard pasted one
of the big advantage of the the
parachute is you can always exchange one
of them well here we are not only
exchanging we are just gaining material
enough so Bishop e1 Bishop b3 Bishop f2
well now you can even say well but okay
I mean you don't have like two extra
pawns you have one extra pawn
yes but I mean here there are another
combined modest because here what what
really kept us in the position that you
start working with the pawns and you
combine another motive which has
appeared here he's very vulnerable King
your King will start going forward
helping your pawns his King is off work
and the B ponies is going nowhere I mean
the bishop or Knight took a control this
pawn at least at the square b6 whenever
he wants and he can repair all these
factors I mean the pawns going forward
your King being much more active like
having an additional piece in the
endgame and of course some even problems
with the getting in here some kind of a
mating net which happens in the game
like Bishop d5 let's say B should be 5
on Seto b3 like at all this point is not
going anywhere because if gets played
before you can play a bit on
so the pawn is not really going because
the pieces cannot support this poem
because they have to cope with with
enemy's passing pawns
majorly you know because very quickly
you play f-5e for king of six King e5
and also some team of the getting met on
on the last rank which is quite a common
one
so f5 you know here basically I think it
something very actually has to happen
not win that's give it happen in a very
solid I've made till the end of the game
one small calculation error it was just
curious because this is what we normally
do in some games so sometimes you have
this kind of let me rush at the end of
the game probably because you're a
little bit tired and I'll show you the
line which I didn't see so here he for
basically here I was expecting you know
very sweeter in the game so that's why
here I missed
so after route d5 I saw this check here
and at first I thought I was you know
giving him mate but then it one line
there was this typical like the rest
image of Sam lie so what I really missed
was not H for which I can kill but on g4
I just didn't see this mode did I give
him checkmate so because of that I
didn't play rook g1 not because of age 4
okay I didn't change the outcome of the
game but still you know here it was a
similar win you're threatening mate and
on h4 you play g6
a couple of checks and then checkmate
probably this was like the best way to
end the game but okay still I think King
f6 you know the game cannot be saved
here g4 trying in some way you know to
to disrupt your pawns but okay with two
posts you can disrupt football sometimes
you can but when they I connected very
very hard so playing with black here is
very easy know g6 like saying okay
are you joking here that the main the
main difference of course is the king
also the king is on h1 basically just
waiting to get mated because okay the
other to me he's waiting to get made it
and also white are waiting
which pawn will arrive first so here
check ok here of course there is no
problem to to give him a pawn because
then you you can bind immediately after
you play a four you see that your next
move will be f3 key here for King
victory here I was really as Ireland
yeah a little bit surprises key still
continues play because ok here nothing
can happen but ok you can never blame
somebody that this keeps playing so okay
in this type of question I prefer even
the day to play because ok I mean
basically you are playing on the dark
keys of the piano because there is
nobody there you alone in the hinder
play hole here Bishop g3 and okay here
he resigned because okay there all kinds
of mating threats from all over so if
the first I'm threatening is he struck
t1 he can play the bishop because then
checking if to me so what he can play if
he plays here let's say how do you win
yeah check King g1 yeah I have to check
yeah you can take and then take F Amanda
yeah you can even you can even you know
just to you can even play this thing now
of course what your set is winning
immediately but you can even play this
know a bit of a joke no Bishop f2 no
bishop f2 is a mating threat with a
matric h1 know if you insist to finish
the game with a maid now yeah so okay
when you have the type of squares like
all for you it's easy to play but of
course okay these are some examples of
games I've played but I but let me show
you because today we are talking with
one of my friends here about some
players from from the past and that was
one very good example a very good
positional play and of course there are
some
additional second let's have a great
player which probably many people here
in from the angle players who go to
never heard of Kim he was served me home
of a very famous in a Russian Grand
Master who had played with all the
champions had a Costco with Karpov had
an eco score with Fischer because he won
the first game and then in the 60 Muriel
games Fisher gave the game after a few
years when he won brilliantly playing
very well with black because he not only
won a brilliant game but after game home
off
he heard homo because he sure knew a
little bit of Russian because he he used
to study Russian to read a lot of chess
magazine yes he heard homo half the game
saying to to one of the Russian other
grandmasters okay he saw everything he
saw everything in that guy play and yeah
he he and he let him in the second game
but especially come off in this game
with with Fischer which is quite famous
the second message were that they played
in 1965 in a grandmaster tournament in
Havana and okay these were other times
and you will not be all you probably
will surprise because the participants
were 22 so they played 21 rounds
nowadays you play like 11 rounds that
the top chess players they need like
seven the rest days and something like
that
but no they played 21 rounds and yeah in
the other days in this particular game
before that game chromophore set the bar
at the hotel drinking Bacardi anyway he
used to drink quite a lot and Smith off
came late by night and told him okay
let's go I'll show you like a line in
chigorin which was the pet line official
so then you'll be able you know to
surprise him okay now first I'll show
this official what are they well when
they write in the katenka shock in the
line but he was completely sure that you
know home off would have forgotten
everything because he was in a state
which was difficult to suspect that he
remember it and in the morning come
often one of the books was describing
what he was feeling
he said okay now he gets some problems
with the authorities in in ex-ussr so he
thought okay now you
playing with Fisher and of course if you
lose this game they don't know that the
previous evening you are drunk as a
skunk so it will become even much more
pleasant and okay so let's get tough and
okay he was sitting on the boat Fisher
was playing from the USA because in this
tournament they didn't give him the
under primal skills playing by the Telex
but only the most incredible ticket that
the same lime appeared on the boat and
he remembered everything the idea which
was shown by him bye bye miss love
and after that he played a very good
traditional game although you know the
situation was quite favorable for him
so very quickly the opening the chigorin
and Fisher was very fond of this plan no
detection c59 f1 which is so very
interesting positional plane get a lot
of experience here and now okay this is
the idea which shot him
of course if he knew this idea Fisher
would have played here probably be three
instead you know on this slide the whole
idea that he's threatening 94 and if you
play b3 at least on this you can get you
know you can hand out the pawns so there
they will not be like like that the team
about a lesson rolling in so easily but
the way he was probably a lot of skins
concentration he's unaware of this video
because way b4 is a very standard very
good please no move you know he fixes
the pawn structure he what's a four and
then tweak exploit you know the better
plan structure and the pair of bishops
but kee missa just one tactical detail
with home of knew beforehand 94 we are
tempering he takes now follows d3 and
what changes in the pigeon well what
change because the depletion still will
have like material equality but what
changes is it now you don't have a pair
of bishops I'll take your LightSquared
Bishop and now my posture perfectly
straight it for my dark-squared bishop
so I have a positional advantage and
after that you'll see it with an iron
hand home off okay now we we know his
motivation he was not only a brilliant
player but he knew that if something
happens in this game in under this
payroll was a contentious then it he'll
not be forgiven
the key after he come back from from
this tournament and in this tournament
he played very well because in 21 rounds
he didn't lose a game so he finished
second with only a half point before the
the winner of the tournament I don't
know who understand what but he never
lost the game in 21 rounds so a lot of
Picardy but no no no yeah I'm not losing
here so a 3d three in architects you
know the LightSquared Bishop you know
like a set key Mike Gminski cares like a
clear position advantage I defend this
from past pawn more space more active
pieces but the main difference is you
know the dark squared Bishop and I think
that although officials tried you know
to get counter play but he played very
well to the end now let's see a
five-night AMG for another poem on light
squares and now a classical
centralization of the pieces look at
five of course for players of this
ranked it was quite natural so these
moves I think were quite easy for home
of kill Queen d7 pointing and Queen d5
no and okay these are the position of
vectors which now is this are difficult
to change so the better pawns back to
the past poem you can get your your
Bishop to become like a better piece
that the the open and Bishop Bishop III
Queen d5 okay of course there is you
know chances tool to get wrongs out for
example here if you if you take with the
pawn suddenly give count to play with
Bishop c5 now I have a past poem also
threatening have led to play a fall will
be a rockin game and okay in the who can
games you always kept I count the play
because the roots can become active one
is behind the past poem which is what we
you know this row that the rook should
be always behind the pawns whether it's
a past our passport or an enemy passed
pawn because this is the base where they
are motive of course each Rock has an
exception but in most of the cases this
is absolutely true
he didn't gave no kind of counter play
group d5 pay for g5
well now the pawns become difficult you
know to be defended
I just gave here one line because it's a
curious one so you play like let's say G
phone instead of g3 because okay I first
Fisher knew he was the incredible
positional player an incredible player
in all aspect of the game he knew that
he should not put the pawn on black but
it was false you know because he liked
that and after the game he congratulated
by the Telex hormone by his good play
okay always you know his behavior behind
the broader Fischer was in macula so no
problem with that
so g3 so if you play g4 just one line
curious GFO here temple move and
unpleasant one no because now it's very
difficult to find like a a good place
for the bishop and if you start like
here bishop h4 and now suddenly you're
losing material now this what I meant is
difficult to find like a good place
hi this was one curious line
he played g3 here Ruka fate now he's
preparing you know king g6 k5 very
natural classic approach so now the King
becomes more active and okay Oh type of
end games now clearly I lost so he tried
in vain some kind of a intend to get
counter play but okay it never succeed
because a home of you know kept control
of the situation
Ruby g8 now he's threatening to get into
the G line now for example this checks
follows the king goes here and still I'm
trying you know to play like Bishop h4
th or depending on the circumstances now
Ruby eight and now the only thing you
have to be careful just not to allow you
know this pintle to persist or for more
time so Ruby salmon and this is like the
beginning of at the end like a for now
to the end
in this stage games you have to kept
some tactical you know alert just not
all only if you play immediately Bishop
a choice if you're winning he'll give
you check and suddenly you have to go
back
you know with the king that's why h5
with a very unpleasant threat h4 I mean
there is no way to to help with this
threat because if you if you play u h4
then I'll follow with room g4 No
so the the penetration of the g5 is
inevitable
so he took here here and now he his king
is completely vulnerable and he got made
it here in a very severe way
all right here there is everything
mating threads the tea pawns of
everything basically oh yeah this was
like a dis a famous game a famous loss
but let me show you just that the same
form of when he played with the young
Kasparov when we see that the same team
how huge his pawns and you know this
basic you know who that ok the pole
should go forward why I mentioned
earlier when we again Kramnik because I
repeat if you look at the games over the
mechanic his path bones gets disability
that whatever he is he's doing and
probably he is doing everything very
very skillfully they are going forward
and they get to promotion who in his
game this is very noticeable so here he
played with a 15 years old Kasparov
although in in this year's Kasparov also
already
everybody in use us assign the chest
worth knew that he'll be like a
potential world champion Sheik an
incredible talent
he was appreciated by both Finnick he
took him in his school and okay he was
like a incredible rising Chester but
okay come off from the old generation
with a very good positional
understanding was able to handle the
young star a very you know how to how to
put it like in English a very remarkable
positional of victory and okay I'll show
you like how that happened for example
the first thing is which I want to
mention is is the opening because Hamas
was never good at opening I mean he
never used to study he didn't get
material so he just used to to look at
the you know at the tournaments what the
other were playing
the only mega deny I think he was right
or some kind of a Soviet chess magazine
which a friend of him talking mid okay
there you could see in some games but
away he was he always paid with a lot of
concentration and he kept like to
describe him coach no he said his type
of chess talent was was incredible this
type of natural talent which is you know
coming from above although the guy never
stayed he has a very hard life as a
young man but still you know he's a
standing of chess was very deep and
here's to play in very good position
just like you see in this game so the
opening was Carolyn because Kasparov
used to play a lot Karen in his younger
years but here he underestimates the
veteran chest lion and now you can see
it even in the open air to Bishop c4 Oh
a wise opening choice but ok this was
like quite natural for for home optical
Jesus used to play like solid lines not
like a principled sharp lines and he of
course it's natural when he played
Bishop c4 and he shortcut or just to
Castle short because then black has a
very solid position you know the kurakin
basically in it's a pawn structure is a
very solid defense so if he Castle so
probably this game would contend it in
and jaw because cause powerful playing
quite well but probably he was too
ambitious he want to show how good is so
he decided quite briskly from static
point view to castle along which in
Kalkan basically you try to follow sweet
so in most of the lines when he castles
along you Castle long of course then
there came some new lines bent Larsen
was one of the pair which in the basic
line with Bishop a5 Bishop g6 started to
play with with short castle and they
started to play a 5 you know his
favorite move for a 5 nh' for with the H
in the a pause so he then introduced a
lot of new ideas but basically earlier
it was like a known rule depending of
where the White Castle in the character
and structures black should follows
exactly the same fashion so here he
plays to ambitiously in the opening I
Kasparov
here an hour long castle
and of course this gave come off a very
easy play because having in mind this
pawn structure how is the back it's very
difficult to imagine getting some play
here against the White King that's why
he played very natural moves here a4 a5
Bishop d2 he's already standing
pleasantly in a pennant picture with a
maybe not too big but clear positional
Danny because it's not it's not very
obvious where is black play he solid ski
down a flag at the record tag but no
visible counter play at first sight rook
e8 he tried to play it solid f6 but now
very good positional move Bishop d3
trying in order to serve some targets
into the the blacks game we should be
faith taketake now he has the better
bone structure and like a classical
player what controls he mere things we
all tries to to keep it fixed like with
a knight on g6 and then tries to to
double his piece against the a6 bone
which gives power off in typical fashion
decided to sacrifice although if he gets
taken here on g3 or so this pigeon also
is quite passive so as part of even in
his older years didn't like passive
position and of course this was not one
of this pigeon which you really like to
enjoy so he decides sacrifice a pawn and
here till the end of the game in my
opinion come off short why why he was
much respected in my he was such a great
player so with a very firm hand he kept
you know pushing his kiss ball and just
providing him with an easy support and
never forget about you know the final
idea that the pawn should be rolling in
although at first sight the end game
looked like with some positional
compensation but let me show he took the
pawn of course ok one now Kasparov
succeeded to exchange quite a few pieces
here and now white guys like even Wilson
here the pawn structure under on the
King side and here case like four
against three
but it seems like ok they are fixed so
maybe you'll never be able you know to
to create like a passport but okay this
is now you see is just an illusion
because the first idea which is part of
casing it okay I can play you know keep
Sara I can play b5 so probably okay
after that it will be difficult for you
to get to penetrate my fortress but okay
with a very logical play he made it
happen so here here the first very well
timed move h4 now he helps his pawns to
to get on double because on g4 he just
wants to play rookie for no rookie foe
and now you can defend the pawn because
okay there is small combination you get
into a lost upon anything though so
that's why I am double my pawns and then
I just need to create protection for
them so rook h1 the power going forward
now if you play G fo you can play but
then you are giving me the f4 square so
the night becomes you know let's let's
see useful that's why he decided not to
give you know this square here but this
means that of course now I'll place my
poem on light squares which is like the
the typical decision when I have like
the the dark squared bishop and also of
course the palm becomes like a protected
passport so kf3 g4 let's remove now
because the poem the pawns on g56 so
they're always a target you can never
you know do something about about the
white pawn so you don't get any kind of
counter play and it was a technical
position here the the important thing
you just activate your pieces which he
did of course in a fairly easy fashion
he's already provided you know I'm much
with his King like II for f5 it's always
available and of course even here you
can see that although it looks here like
the pawns can fix the the white pawn but
you always get this idea because the
basic square is not available for the
night so you always after some time you
have the idea with d5 and to to get with
the King on d4
and the poll on a6 probably is like the
ultimate target so let me show you just
just how it finish it in a quite a
technical way firstly activated the
bishop no now he uses the passport
mainly to get to deflect the enemy
pieces and then he attacks his pawns
here on the on the Queen side by
activating the King d5 King D from
Bishop g7 Bishop g7 basically you know
what he tries to show is that the the
Black Knight does not get any useful
square now he could have paid to Luke h3
but I think the King D 5 uses like the
best decision just keep going with the
King although he sacrificing all the
power on g4 but activity was like the
most important for him check and now he
goes after the oh he didn't took it
immediately because he didn't want you
know just to get some technical
difficulties here now the King can get
them into trouble so no need you know to
give any kind of card to play so you
play King b6 the black pawn YY the black
pawn cannot go on because okay basically
the transformation of which entails
becoming in saturated the bishop is
better than that then the knight or the
bishop controls the night and why
controls the night because the bishop
now is in open position so the vision
has opened a lot I have a poll on 87 and
you're to pass pawns
I easy to control because I have that
the piece of a longer range which is the
bishop here you can move that pawn
because the knight is hanging here again
attacking the pawns and now he just goes
into a very easy in easily one rookin
game now if he goes through cage three
he just picks up the pawns now I start
pushing so he played the last move here
rookie 7 rook takes from g4 well ok I
mean the big difference of the of the
Kings he is more than obvious and after
a few moves
preparing rook g6 here is I so like I
told you even it was 1978
and Kasparov 15 years old well I think
that the first victory against
Grandmaster he did when he was 14 years
old who he was a a very very good player
but who most you can can keep you know
his chest lengthen delivered even
against okay this was the only game he
played with with Kasparov and it's good
to say that he thinks that both
carpeting Kasparov are great players but
Tori he's sliding in favor for power
disc is person of you so this is our
lecture for today about the the rolling
pawns and I like to wish you that also
in your games the pawns keep rolling in
and then in getting a promotion in in
high rate
you